the association agreements and the trade
area that we have in place are in the
interests of and benefit to Moldovan
citizens and European Union citizens and
this is why we have to work together to
make sure that all parts of it are
implemented as always you can count on
us you can count on the European Union
to be there as a strong partner and
friend we agreed that it is essential
for Moldova to focus on the full
implementation of reforms in key sectors
such as justice media energy and the
business sector with the understanding
that all reforms should be sustained and
based on a continued concerted fight
against corruption and a strong support
for the rule of law this includes
investigations on the banking fraud
which we expect to be finalized without
any further delay with a view to
recovering the misappropriated funds and
to bringing all those responsible to
justice irrespective of their status or
political affiliation
we have been demanding this for many
years we expect now this to happen as
the current situation is difficult for
us to understand this is about the
credibility of the anti-corruption
reforms in Moldova as well as the
credibility towards the Moldovan
citizens who cannot and must not be the
ones to pay for the costs of this
situation transparent inclusive and
credible elections at Central and local
levels are of key importance any change
to the electoral system should be based
on a broad consensus among political
forces following a genuine consultation
of civil society and in accordance with
the recommendations of relevant
international partners when it comes to
the Transnistrian settlements the latest
significant positive developments that
we have witnessed
will serve to bring tangible benefits to
the populations on both banks of the
nistru river the European Union will
continue to support a peaceful
settlement of the Transnistrian conflict
within the framework of the 5+2 process
general isn't this cozy lady esterases
Punk Assunta man chorus da angusamy Otto
Clara when you in a European the
acquaintance also furious presenter in
Austrian by multi
domaine noel ren-dono Sravan fat [ __ ]
broken traffic alleged a European
Republic II Moldova quod erat
irreversible objective tech Iranian
proposed dialogue boon and she put all
mandatory she is the party important
Cooper allegedly Parliament re-implement
area Cordova Susheela ceremony priori
Tata numero uno a governor a delusional